[Music]
good morning everyone rob hello good
morning
uh peter here and rob here uh the switch
is coming out next week uh we've got one
and we've had a lot of time to play with
zelda you only talk about the first five
hours so today we're going to show you
some of the gameplay we're going to talk
about what we've done what we like uh
what we hope for the future of the game
and we're going to talk about the switch
a little bit
uh yeah so rob um i'm having a good time
with switch so far but i'm curious how
you're feeling about the hardware at
this point
yeah in general uh you know i've been
doing the uh the two switches i guess
you could say which is i've um played on
a television with this and then i've
used the controller
to do so
and
i'd say my favorite so far has been
actually just doing the handheld
dude yeah i'm finding the same thing
because i go home with all the gear
right because i want to play at home and
then i think well okay i'll just set it
up but i don't even get to that stage i
pick it up and start playing for a
minute
and then hours later it's like oh wow
this is actually working pretty well
it's just that first gimmick from the
first trailer right of the actual switch
yeah but it it really was cool like it
was late at night it was like 1am for me
and i like was like all right i'm just
gonna stop capturing i was gonna get in
bed and it reminded me of like having
like i never had a ds actually but like
back in the day like game boy with that
stupid magnifying light in order to like
you know actually see the screen and i'm
just doing that in bed with my pillows
propped up and
i played till 5 30 a.m
like non-stop and it was really really
awesome all right so uh
are you concerned about anything right
now because i know uh battery life is a
concern for a lot of people i was able
to get about three hours just under
three hours playing with airplane mode
on at full brightness uh with zelda
which i felt like was pretty good
because this is not like a ds right like
the games we're playing on here are much
more high-end um so i'm not terribly
like upset about that but it is slightly
disappointing to know that i basically
have to keep this tethered and i won't
be able to play like on a long flight i
haven't had any luck charging over a usb
battery though that's supposed to work
yeah i i wouldn't be one to say anything
about battery life just because yeah i
mean i'm playing in my bed i might as
well just like have this thing charged
um and
yeah utilizing that um but
i don't know i mean we've talked about
this like for me that's fine because i
you sure as hell i'm not gonna play it's
on the bus
uh i i guess flights would be the one
concern right like hopefully it's a uh
it's a nice flight where they have like
an outlet or something but for the most
part
um i'm pretty content with just
you know watching tv with it or you know
doing just like household uh situations
i guess you could say
one gwx on the chat is asking if we've
been experiencing the disconnect issues
for the left joy con
i've seen a lot of these reports i've
had no problems
just i've not heard this disconnect what
uh so apparently the left joy con is
losing sync with the console which is
causing like in zelda like so like the
analog stick if you're pushing left and
you let go it'll still think it's
pushing left because the sync is messed
up
and there's been a few videos out there
game explain did a pretty thorough
investigation of this uh for a while it
seemed like it was just limited to the
colored controllers but i guess it sends
blood over to just the gray ones i
haven't had this problem it sounds
really crappy though if you're
experiencing it i really hope that's not
an issue day one
um i have not uh had much of that at all
yeah
uh mark hernandez wants to know uh how
are loading times uh well for zelda i
guess that's pretty much the only game
we can talk about building times aren't
that bad like when you initially boot up
like yeah there's you know maybe 20
seconds or so
yeah i would say uh
if you were tr
no i'm thinking oh jesus i was thinking
of horizon zero dawn now i think about
it uh no the only thing um i would say
yeah you know if you die it's pretty
generous uh there's a lot of auto saves
you're going right back to you know and
it doesn't take too long it's just a few
seconds of loading yeah it's not bad at
all yeah and zelda doesn't install into
the system either uh it's basically just
running off the card so uh i guess maybe
that's why the loading times aren't too
bad but thankfully yeah that's the case
because horizon zero dawn has pretty
long loading times when you're fast
traveling yeah i was gonna say for that
game like if you're the farther you go
the longer it is right but uh no for the
in this case it's it's fine i mean no
complaints but i mean the best part
about breath of the wild is actually
like no loading times as far as like
just getting wherever you want on
horseback or foot like
it's pretty consistent yeah uh let's see
traffic wants to know do you need a grip
for the joy cons it might just be the
size of my hands but honestly this thing
like fits in there really well and i
don't feel like i'm gonna drop the
system it's not that heavy uh and it's
just kind of like slots into my hands
like
i could imagine wanting some sort of
grip to like as you can see there's
fingerprints on the screen like i don't
want to get grime on this thing yeah but
that's just because it's like a really
nice piece of hardware
but in terms of just practical
functionality i don't think you're going
to need grips unless
maybe you have really small or large
hands it's not going to fall out your
hands
it's i would say it's also got enough
weight to where like it's it's just
secure like there's enough like yeah as
you said like grip uh the yeah the mat
is fine
you know the only thing if we want to
talk about controllers is initially this
was
kind of frustrating in that like you're
um with with the joy-cons in there your
fingers
you know obviously want to wrap around
all the way so they're kind of like
hitting the joy cons and it feels a
little off at first but eventually you
know you just kind of come to terms with
terms with it and i was fine with it
yeah you have been using the pro
controller yes and
people are going to think i'm crazy but
this is my favorite modern video game
controller really i think it's really
comfortable it's got this like leather
finish on the grip which uh which feels
kind of it's not that it feels nice it
just feels it makes it like when you put
it in your hand it feels like you're
holding a pillow or something jeez uh
it's super comfortable and the inputs
are all great some people were talking
about the triggers like oh they prefer
the playstation 4 style but man i've had
no problems with this thing so far i
actually like it a lot um but i've also
had a decent experience playing with
just the joy cons like one in each hand
playing zelda not in this
really you've been doing that i did it a
little bit so i was uh going to the
grocery store with my girlfriend the
other day and
i decided to sit in the car so i could
play switch while she went in there and
i set it up on the dashboard took the
joy-cons out and i was just
sitting there playing
it was fine it was it was good so if the
thing that you're describing with this
where it feels like it's too uh you know
like close like your hands are knocking
into each other yeah you could you can
literally just hold them in each hand
and work just fine presuming that you
don't have any of those you know out of
sync issues for the left joy con
uh damn let's see another question about
uh storage on uh the switch when you
install zelda you don't install zelda uh
thankfully just runs right off the card
so it will not eat up any of your 25
gigabytes of memory uh the operating
system eats up about six gigabytes uh so
it's a 32 gigabyte storage but only 25
accessible
uh question can you give me one reason
to buy the switch from abdullah
al-kasami akasimi sorry if i pronounced
your name wrong it's tough uh
one reason to buy the switch i mean the
first five hours of zelda have me pretty
stoked about keeping my pre-order yeah
i'm honest yeah i'm on the same boat
with you yeah uh it's
we'll talk about it now or later i don't
know it's it's a fantastic game
uh let's see if people have a few other
questions edc is wondering how this
looks in sunlight i actually haven't
really tested it out in sunlight too
much yeah i mean i've just been playing
at night indoors uh that's a good point
yeah we don't have one two switch yet so
we're not going to parks and playing
games with strangers
laughing
i mean that's my fear right like there's
just no way i mean this it's such a nice
looking screen like someone just like
i just have that fear of someone's
jacking it
yeah
jacking it i feel fear we all have
there's one thing i would say is what i
was doing is like you know i was
i took an uber to work one and i put it
in my side um jacket one thing that was
like despite these things being like
really secure onto the lcd
screen there was still this fear of like
these getting bent out of shape or
something like that like it's not
it is very secure but there's something
about yeah that is kind of scary almost
like the what was the iphone 6 idea of
like putting in your back pocket and
laying that screen like there's i want a
case you want some kind of carrying
device with this thing yeah i didn't
bring it on set but i've been using i
guess the official nintendo branded
carrying case for this um which is
pretty great i don't actually know how
much it costs unfortunately but um it's
like just what you need it's just sturdy
enough
um and you know so to your point about
these things being a little fragile i've
been like
trying to like torque them a little bit
like to see what happens if i get super
excited because this uses motion
controls right so
i could see if you're playing something
like mario kart you know you're kind of
going at it pretty hard uh
it feels like there's like a a slight
give if you really try to move these
things but but by and large like
they're in there pretty well um
yeah i will say taking these controllers
off
it it kind of takes as a process it
takes getting used to yeah because it
doesn't slide off like all that easily
which i think is probably speaking to
the fact that it feels so sturdy um
i it's funny you're doing it at the same
time i haven't really
done that at the same time i i've been
like using both hands for each one and
then like pulling them off i don't know
amateur
amateurs uh all right let's see uh is
there a media player like the ps4 asks
atari jaguar cd uh not yet uh nintendo i
don't think has said whether or not
we're going to see something like that i
would be very surprised if nintendo
allowed that to happen
traditionally they like to protect what
is on their systems even if it's not you
know going online and sharing that
content so
my hunch is we probably won't get that
but that remains to be seen there there
is a micro sd card slot on here so you
can expand um and you know take
screenshots off the system at the moment
just regular sd microsd cards work sdxc
i think that's going to be available in
a day one patch
uh so you'll get faster memory transfers
but uh yeah it's just under the
kickstand it's actually hard to find
yeah if you don't know it's there um i
don't know if get a close-up on that
whoop yeah buddy zulman
let me see here so yeah it's that little
slot right there
right there right there this one
that one
um
yeah let's see what else is there to
talk about with the hardware do you like
the stand
do i like the stand um i haven't used it
the you mean the oh i'm sorry
so i will say this the angle that it
pops out to
isn't what i call ideal um it's probably
hard for the camera to replicate how i
feel because that looks like it's
pointing directly at it
but from my perspective the screen is
pointing like at my chest not on my face
and you only have one setting for this
stand right so what i've actually been
doing is when i've i have played it on a
coffee table while sitting on the couch
um i will actually lean it on the
carrying case
which then angles it up in my face so i
actually have a hard time imagining how
you would use this stand like unless
it's at like a
like something like a really high table
like a bar table but that's not that's
not the way this thing is meant to work
so uh it actually would be nice to see
if we could kick this out a little bit
more
but um yeah i mean i'm sure companies
are going to be selling like foldable
like proper stands for this thing
i worry this is a little bit flimsy as
well
it's got some give there is a metal
hinge on the inside so it's not all
plastic thankfully but um you know it is
a thing that is sort of sticking out you
never really know what might happen
um
did you just mention the
the case you had had like a stand in it
is that what we were thinking no that's
not that's not a stand technically so
that's like a thing that folds over a
screen to protect
the screen but also hold game cards it
actually was a little bit hard for me to
figure out what to do with that because
it folds in a strange way
but no i've been just leaning it like on
the case like just closed on the desk
um
if there's if there's one thing about
the button layout that i actually
have not oh yeah not too jazz about are
these uh plus and minus ones right here
specifically this one right here uh the
minus on the left uh joy con it's just
hard to get to without you have to crane
your thumb like over the analog stick
right it's kind of a chore um
but then again yeah right here it's it's
i've many of times i've done something
unintentional like
in zelda you know take out a bomb in
front of a group of people and then they
look at me like really terrified
um or
yeah but in general um i don't know is
this is this the same for the pro like i
mean it looks pretty uh the pro feels
great
in regards to that yeah i definitely do
uh have a similar experience with this
button it is super super small uh which
is and and the fact that it's not really
in a great spot does make it very hard
to press and compared to the other
buttons it's
it doesn't really it's not as much
raised as the other ones you kind of
have to you kind of have to like give it
all you got with your thumb yeah yeah
but whatever
um let's see
uh
are there any games that come with it no
you don't get any games with this thing
unfortunately um bummer yeah
but i think they're looking at eight
games at launch maybe there's like one
or two that have snuck in there zelda is
really the biggest one uh one two switch
is super interesting in our experience
we did a live stream the other week uh
which was i've tried to explain that
game to people and they
they don't seem to like and i'm like oh
it's so exciting it's so weird and
different they're like okay
but you you really have to play one two
switch to like like understand how crazy
it is like it sounds like i'm
advertising but it's just genuine like
that game is is weird and fun yeah i
want to see the all the other games
right like there's like 25 yeah yeah
yeah i mean yeah people have been saying
it it's a shame it didn't come with it
right yeah um yeah but yeah
yeah um are the bezels too big and are
the buttons too small well uh i don't
mind the bezel actually like with this
here i can turn it on and we can look at
the
menu screen
so
i mean yeah there is a bezel but in
practice when you're holding this thing
it doesn't feel i don't feel like i'm
looking at a screen surrounded by a lot
of product if that makes sense unlike
the wii u gamepad so this and the wii u
gamepad have the exact same dimensions
for their screen they're both 6.2 inches
and the gamepad by comparison has a
gigantic bezel across all sides this is
so much more sleek and i've been
actually really happy with the
dimensions of the screen relative to the
system and the size of the system itself
it feels like
like a graduated vita in a way you know
what i mean yeah absolutely yeah it's
like high-end portable games but this
hardware is a lot more interesting
and there's no back touch pad to piss me
off
uh jorge reese wants to know any lag
using the joy cons none that i can
detect um so i think we've been pretty
good there someone mentioned uh what
happens if i crack my screen do we do
you're hosed partner yeah is that
basically i mean you mean i wonder if
you can buy i mean obviously the joy-con
controllers and i think the dock they've
stated have a price but that's the
console right like yeah i mean you
couldn't i don't even think you could
buy a replacement gamepad from nintendo
if you lost yours you had to like go on
ebay and buy one from someone else or
millions in and get it fixed
um i mean this is the meat of the system
so you know what has me really curious
though is like okay everything is
detachable from this
what what is stopping nintendo from just
releasing new standalone upgrades down
the down the road i mean the system
isn't out yet we have no freaking clue
but
i'm excited about the idea that like
this thing has a bunch of different
parts that are separate from one another
and what that can mean for upgrades
there's been a lot of talk too about you
know special attachments where the joy
cons go like based on certain games
um
it's from a hardware perspective
you know this isn't a review but
personally i really like this and i
think that it's just got a lot of like
really interesting features and a great
build quality
um all right should we probably start
talking about zelda
that's what people are here for i guess
yeah yeah oh yeah i think so
that's what i want to talk about the
most all right
can
we roll a little bit of footage right
started so that's the plan we have uh
a hands-on preview that uh you and i put
together i got it and it's uh on our
site
and youtube um and we're going to talk
over it and kind of give more in depth
of like what this game is about yes as
well as other um
pieces of video that we have um
the
combat uh highlight reel combat and cool
stuff and cool stuff some some cool
stuff from our facebook channel but yeah
let's get to it
bam so this is from the uh almost the
opening scene when you sort of emerge
into the world and
it's big
it's really really big
uh inside here this is one of the trial
dungeons so the world has about 100 of
these according to nintendo these are
just like you know a few minutes a piece
bite size puzzles um i've only
experienced puzzles in them at this
point
and they start off easy yeah they start
off they start off easy but you know and
and the puzzles like change quite a bit
like there's one that used the motion
controls to tilt like a sort of like a
maze i did that one yeah yeah super cool
uh they're a lot of fun they're a great
change of pace
um there have been a couple though that
i've i would say three uh namely that i
but i've entered and then left because i
had i had no idea how to do it oh really
yeah and then on the map it it kind of
highlights like hey dude you haven't
finished the shrine so you can always go
back and warp there conveniently yeah um
because some of them seemed down the
road to uh so that's dying that's dead
so just on top of this comes
very quickly in this game if you are not
prepared or if you sort of
uh
man
so yeah you and i had the same
experience climbing a mountain uh your
stamina is affected so once that runs
out you're falling yeah and uh but
however in rain
the game goes like a little prompt pumps
uh pops up and goes hey guess what uh
during a thunderstorm or rain uh you
can't climb yeah and then you're falling
you can like climb a little bit but you
just slip right back down right a couple
questions in the chat real quick l ask
is breath of the wild difficult enough
so far the game uh is happy to let you
die uh even running into a fight with
multiple common enemies if you don't
have your wits about you they can kill
you pretty quickly it just takes one or
two hits from them to deplete your
hearts so this game is in my mind
challenging enough but challenging in a
way that teaches you to play zelda
differently i mean it's it's i think i
came into this expecting combat to be a
little bit more forgiving right where
like yeah link sort of always had the
upper hand in the past but here enemies
you know they'll poke at you with this
long stick like you have to how do you
get past that because they can keep you
at bay like there's a lot of scenarios
where you find yourself like having a
problem problem solve uh during combat
there was just one there and i was
looking at footage and realized what was
going on is uh one of those uh bokoblins
actually nailed it on that name was
spinning
a pole around
and you could crouch below it and but i
s but i was doing that and i stood up
and then i got knocked so like that's
just like one of many ways where you the
game just lets you figure out uh how to
deal with these dudes yeah like it
introduces sort of the bigger concepts
of like okay here's what combat is
here's how it works like you know uh
people may give you a hint like oh yeah
you should probably be careful when this
happens but there's not really like
you know like tutorial driven sections
you'll get like a pop like a splash
screen with some info at most but you
really have to learn on the fly
everything in this game and it's it's
combat it's how to explore and not die
by being too ambitious it's i mean
i learned how to tame a horse but
apparently you went somewhere where they
they kind of explained it but right but
you don't even need that like this game
is intuitive enough
that even with the basic rule set and
all the layers it has you can still
figure out what to do
yeah that's what was the first thing
that i think blew uh
of the people playing in the office when
we
blew our minds when we all came in and
we had played two three hours and
what you did what you didn't do that
everyone has different stories and that
continues to today like i
i keep i keep expecting to hear people
say oh yeah yeah i know i've done that
already and no that's not the case right
um
as someone who's reviewing this game i'm
personally terrified
uh because it just seems like there is
so much to do and again the world is
gigantic um i feel like i'm spending
all my time just exploring because you
know what it's fun
um very fun but then i keep finding
myself like all right i need to get to
the story now and it's
you have to travel pretty far and then
you get caught up in something else you
discover a dog you want a pet and become
friends with like
that took up 20 minutes of my time just
hanging out with a dog and i was like
wait what was i doing again right that
is definitely a case uh it's not you
know frustrating but it's all right
stay on track don't get distracted
because there's so much to do um
yeah someone asked if you lose anything
when you die it's very much like a
standard zelda game right where you just
i think you lose a heart
it's uh well like if i
upon respawning when you die you don't
lose any of your stuff
you don't listen to your stuff i think
you respond with full health oh do you
yeah but no you get to keep all of the
currency and items and things that you
have and it sort of restarts you because
it's pretty generous with autosave like
you said so it restarts you not too far
back from where you were playing
um
so how does this feel like to you in
terms of being a zelda game because
there's a lot of things in here that you
know people have said to me like yeah
assassins creed did that yeah far cry
does that are these things just cool
because it's the first time it's in a
zelda game um
what's your interpretation of that
because it's this is this does kind of
feel like two different things but it
also is just one thing like i feel like
it's hard to compare it to those games
yeah you kind of just said it uh it is
so zelda and in every way uh ocarina of
time is like my favorite yeah uh for
sure and i've replayed that game so many
times and i'm getting a lot of those
vibes a lot of those like
tropes of zelda that fit in really
nicely and then yes like the thing
that's surprising but it does mesh so
well is this survival yeah kind of
western influence that is
has been a trend and people have been
you know like you think of all the games
in the last three years like daisy all
these like
early access like you're out there you
got to eat food to survive weather's a
factor it just feels so natural let me
explain the food thing because it's not
like you need food to
satiate hunger necessarily right but
let's say you're climbing up to a cold
mountain
link will freeze if he doesn't have the
right armor but you can negate the need
for armor by cooking a dish with hot
peppers you can't just eat hot peppers
but you have to combine them in a dish
and the game like kind of tells you this
but i didn't know it i had to talk to
someone and get that info um and so
because the survival aspect is so
important to this game and there are so
many layers to consider it really does
create this awesome dialogue with other
people playing the game that feels like
something i haven't experienced in
decades like since i was a kid right
like sharing secrets before the internet
was a thing like i can't wait until more
people have this in their hands and we
can finally see like all the things that
the four of us playing haven't seen yet
because i'm sure there's a lot only in
the small slice of the game yeah
it's
it's we we've said this before it's one
of those things where
in your head because the game is you
know not force-feeding you tutorials
yeah more or less but in your head you
think
i wonder if i can can i do that yeah
99 of the time you can generally do that
uh
it's it's a joy like you it it's
pretty like at its core it's it's like
humanistic i don't know there's
something about like well you know in
your own life like for instance an apple
horses like apples
i wonder if i can give a horse an apple
you know the the dog situation so when i
found that dog it didn't give me a
button prompt to pet it and i'd cut i
thought to myself what happens if i
kneel down close to it and link brought
his face up to like rub on the dog's
face it was like the
man like of course that works and the
dog like emitted hearts because there's
a thing that the game wanted you to do
incredible uh somebody was asking uh
does the system feel hot after playing
for a while i've had no problems with
that playing in handheld mode no
problems picking it up out of the dock
for about a minute or two it'll feel
warm but it runs really efficiently and
cool um on the handheld itself when
you're playing it in that mode yeah i
mean i was i said before i was in bed
playing it for like five hours uh with
the ac plugged in and
no i mean maybe like a slight warmth of
it but it could have been
me
i don't know
uh yeah not a problem so john evans is
stating that docked is about 900p and
undocked is 720. undocked is true at 720
but in the system settings you can
actually see a 1080p option when
changing the resolution on the tv now i
don't know if that is stretching in 980p
native resolution or not
but uh in some respects this is 1080 if
you want it to be
um do you wanna talk about like frame
rate anything like that let's talk about
frame rate yeah um
about a minute after starting the game i
saw some really bad frame rate problems
and initially it had me it had me really
concerned because it was it was
egregious to the point where i was like
i don't know if i want to
play this entire game experiencing these
problems
that said it's kind of disappeared
it's weird because i had similar
uh issues or thoughts even yeah like oh
really i'm not really
you know when you when you
tend to let frame rate drops be like
okay is like in like high action intense
moments you're like you kind of like can
step away like all right well that's
understandable but for me yeah in the
beginning uh even as simple as a pan in
a grassy field was like oh that was it
it was a really lush field that allowed
for really long draw distances across a
huge like plane or valley
so in those scenarios you might notice a
little bit of frame rate stuff but yes
by and large it looks
really good and i'd say the frame rate
issues are less apparent when you're
playing it portably
that was the weirdest thing too yeah
like uh
i never once have i seen any kind of
frame rate drop while playing uh
handheld yeah same and i dropped the
dock settings down when this was docked
to 720p versus 1080p to see what
happened didn't notice a difference
there
yeah so it's it's curious to see that
and it might be a little bit of a
letdown
but that said it really doesn't define
the experience it seems like whenever i
see it again it's almost like oh okay i
guess that was a thing that i forgot
about uh yeah and i haven't been
noticing it that that much either like
later on um and i don't know exactly
what like whether that's me just like
used to it but
regardless uh is not at all like
affecting my time with it yeah um
um yeah uh to bring it back to combat
someone else in the chat sorry i didn't
see the name there's a lot of things
flowing through uh asked about weapons
breaking mid-combat
this is
maybe one thing that i'm
i've had to learn to live with
uh so most of your weapons early on will
break after fighting just a few enemies
which can feel really frustrating now
like the flip side of that coin is that
every enemy you defeat drops a weapon
that you can then pick up so you're
never really out of weapons to use but
the problem is when you get something
cool
you want to use it and you want to feel
like you own it
but then when you get that indication
like hey your thing's about to break
it's like
man like i can't use this weapon right
now
so i don't know what to expect like
i think you're gonna get items that have
better durability i think that makes
sense but
will you ever get items that will never
break
is there gonna be a way to repair
weapons that you leave in that
semi-broken state before they actually
shatter because if you use a weapon
until it breaks it breaks and it's gone
right it's not like oh take it to go get
fixed it explodes
it does actually kind of yeah
so that's a bit strange and the game
doesn't really apart from that one
little warning and like maybe a little
bit of text in the item description you
don't have like a granular indication of
how much durability is left on your
weapon uh which i think would be super
helpful because sometimes i'd
i don't know it's
it's really disheartening to break
something that you like and feel like
cool i gotta fight with a club now i had
this awesome sword before but
i guess i'm basic and back to beginning
yeah you you kind of uh
it's tough yeah you kind of said it like
you just have this inclination to be
like all right like i'll just save this
for something like important i guess but
then you're not ever using it you don't
look as cool
uh
the
shields also break
which sucks because snowboarding is i
mean you're not on snow all the time you
can board on your shield anywhere that
there's a decline like a hill
and it is freaking addictive
you talk about getting distracted i see
a mountaintop and i'm like i wonder if i
can paraglide off that and
carve that up dude yeah it's it's so
much fun but then you get the indication
that your shield broke and uh i don't
know it's i guess it's a thing we have
to live with i don't know that it's a
great thing
like there's enough survival in this
game like in terms of the physicality of
link um
that i don't know that i wanted to apply
to equipment at least so harshly but
we're super early into this game there's
a lot left to play so things might
change there's got to be yeah some kind
of um
yeah you said it like just like some
kind of shield that is just made
to snowboard you know what i mean i'm
hoping once i meet the gorons if they're
in this game if they have like a
boarding slope
they better [ __ ] car some lava
no but i'm hoping like they have some
sort of forge where i can like give them
like you know a metal piece of equipment
and have them like right make it
stronger or something like that i feel
like for all of the little details that
this game gets right and unexpected
variables that are present in the most
basic elements
i it's like i don't think it's crazy to
hope for those sort of things like i
feel like this won't be a problem but
i'm just wishful thinking yeah uh and
again this is such a like a sandbox
like open world where you just
experiment and i think this is better uh
than ever to show oh john luke put on
this clip uh we can talk more about this
but eventually i want to talk about um
some of the stuff that we figured out
um
just by experimentation so this is
actually this is me throwing this uh
bomb around on that bokoblin and he
didn't know i was up there and i kept
doing it forever and ever
it's just
there's still something to be said like
i want to experiment more with um
your runes or abilities you have like
this is one of them here that you get uh
you know infinite bombs um they're
addicting because they're infinite um
and link has this amazing thing where
when he wants the bomb to explode he
pushes his hand out like he's casting us
sorry interrupted you but no no no
i love that detail so much um
and there's like a good use for like any
kind of like crappy weapon right is to
throw it yes um
or when you get the oh here's the moment
you were talking about putting in the
dog um
you just yeah i get the ram i heard that
uh the rams died pretty funny they just
freeze um
chickens this does have the classic
chicken
scenario from zelda games yeah yeah
you'll you know exactly like right when
i saw chickens i was like all right okay
so this tree
what's really interesting about that
which we didn't get to see but i saw
another video so that still has physics
applied to it right it's not like a
thing that is like fixed that once it
falls it's not going to move anymore oh
so i saw someone fell a tree over a
little canyon got to the other side he
started walking on it because he wasn't
walking directly in the center of it the
log started to roll
and then him and the log fell down the
ravine
like damn you know what i mean like for
so this game allows you to do so much
but you still have to be able to execute
on those options using the abilities
that you have within the like you know
the game's rules
throw them up at a skeleton why not
clean them up
uh yeah handle it so another thing with
like hand gliding and stamina if you can
see you are taking away your stamina
while hang gliding so there there are
these situations where you're rock
climbing and you're not gonna make it to
the legend time so you gotta
jump off the wall and hand glide guess
what now you have no stamina for hand
gliding and you're falling oh there's a
river below me thank god i can land on
that and you know be safe from the uh
fall you're drowning down
immediately because you need stamina to
swim it's just
you have to think ahead and also that's
where cooking plays into effect right
like yeah you can cook um
meals hearty hearty meals that will get
you through uh
tough situations i find myself hoarding
meat because like meat is the basis for
a lot of meals right but then like you
find a lot of items that are like oh if
you mix this in maybe you'll be able to
run faster or maybe you can sneak you
know and be a little bit quieter um it's
there are so many recipes in this game
it's really hard to keep track and at
the moment like the sheikah tablet in
the game will be upgraded a few times
with new stuff even this early in the
game but what i haven't seen yet is
something that keeps track of what you
craft yeah
uh i think that's going to be super
important because
you can really gain a big advantage if
you make the right meal or create the
right elixir before going into a battle
or even trying to climb a high mountain
or even a huge disadvantage of making
the wrong meal oh yeah because i've done
that a bunch of times and it just spits
it goes right and it spits out something
that's like it's calm it's pretty i'm
not gonna spoil it but it's like
nothing you want brown stew sure
um
yeah i call you off there i don't know
what we're talking about exactly but
yeah cooking is great
uh oysten v leftjoycon has crazy input
lag and sync issues just to reiterate we
really haven't had those problems um i
was really surprised to see those pop up
online um and i kind of sympathize with
everyone because i would be really upset
if that happened to mine i'm a little
worried yeah
specifically with these right well that
was the trend but apparently now it
looks like the gray ones might also be
experiencing issues for some people ouch
but i haven't seen it like fingers
crossed you know right yeah absolutely
um
i wanted uh to show a cool clip of
something really cool
let's do it
show that one of the states stasis oh
yes um
to give you an idea of the creativity in
this game uh if we can get this clip
pulled up
hopefully i don't want to spoil it okay
here it is so stasis lets you
so it happens real quick just to recap
stasis lets you freeze certain objects
and then uh use like kinetic energy more
or less
you can impart energy onto it and it'll
build up and then when the time freeze
runs out wherever you put that energy
it will then react as though you're
putting all of it into it at once so rob
did this to take out a book goblin
on that thing which is just
it's evidence of the creativity that's
possible in this game if you play smart
and really pay attention to all of your
options in your environment right like
those things were in around this
encampment god dammit it's just fun it's
not even to like progress in the game
it's just like i just want to do this
stuff because why the hell not
yeah and that's
just like that video right there i'm so
excited to see down the road just gifts
right because we saw them at e3 and
that's what really you know took me by
storm was like oh my god this game looks
incredible yeah uh there were there was
hours of footage coming out of e3 and
all of it looked like so interesting and
different yeah and is there this thing
where like you were playing and it's
like you know
there's a boulder on top of a mountain
and now whenever i see that
i'll save the game yeah and then i'll do
what you just saw
i want to see how far i can get launched
into space maybe who knows
uh let's see uh this world looks fun
this world is really fun
so far yeah yeah i'm hoping for some
sort of like boarding park
like a stunt course there has to be and
and just thinking of that is cool then
thinking about the characters oh yeah
oh man because that's something we
haven't really i guess we've maybe
brushed slightly on but like the the
characters in this game and i would say
by far almost every character
feels
well polished crafted and
and unique and funny and just there's a
sense of humor for each one of them
makes you chuckle it's like so charming
so i found this
i don't know if i can spoil it yeah i
mean we should probably
i know what do we do there's a lot of
really tight restrictions here uh expect
a lot of bad puns
um there was okay so there's this one
merchant i met on the road
and he had this like existential crisis
within him or something because you know
i bought my items and then i was saying
goodbye goes all right i'll see you
later or maybe not no point worrying
about things we can't control
just bow his head and walk away yeah
you're just like okay
like damn guy
yeah
um but it just like there's a i don't
know like it's i think that there's a
lot of evidence in this game that that
nintendo still knows what it's doing or
they know how to get the right people
involved in certain games i think if you
look at games like metroid prime
federation force it's like why is this
out like
nintendo has had a weird history a
recent history of releasing things that
just seem maybe off base right that it
doesn't really represent uh what people
loved about the series that these
sequels are a part of
but this game does like in every sense
of it like i feel
like i said in my preview it feels like
the first time i played ocarina of time
again because
the personality of the world is very
similar but also the mechanics and
everything else about the the game
itself is so new and novel that it's
like ocarina of time felt like a
revolution this feels like a revolution
for zelda but
but even for open world games yeah which
is tough to say like i i was stoked
about horizon i really liked it
but playing zelda is almost making me
question like
jeez
like horizon's a great game oh yeah yeah
it's a great it's a fantastic game but
next to this it's like
shoot like
i ca if i was to make a list of all the
things i liked about the open world
aspect of these games like the zelda one
would be twice as long i think yeah
everything
i think we're like looping but like
everything in in zelda so far like seems
to have
a reason
but
someone has thought about
all the relationships that i mean i'm
talking about a rock yeah like you know
it feels like a rock has a relationship
with and connection in the in the way of
like you know sandbox experimentation
somebody like a character everything
seems so interconnected i think someone
threw a rock at me this morning and i
hit it back with a sword
i think i hit it like a baseball bat
yeah because he's
the physics model in this game alone
like we were describing with the tree
and with the rock and stuff like that
and the snowboarding it's just and then
it's it's the challenge yeah and and and
the game is is [ __ ] excuse me what's
so great about showing you
uh
something that is not uh as uh tutorial
based for instance you uh you walked
over my desk you're like dude
boomerang
you throw the boomerang
and just like most zelda games it comes
back to you you know on its own you have
to catch the boomerang you have and the
timing of it you have like half a second
to hit the a button to catch the
boomerang when it comes back like
and the only and the only one and what i
meant by like the like the really like
uh
subtle uh tutorial of that is you see
that prompt you just see a prompt for
half a second it says catch yeah and you
go no there's no one who's like hey i
like boomerangs let me teach you how to
use a boomerang like it's it's up to you
and boomerangs act as melee weapons now
too so they're not limited to just being
thrown you can use them as a sword or
you know a close range weapon if you
need to because because why not because
because that would make logical sense it
seems to be that's why it's in this game
like so many things and the other thing
about the freaking boomerang is that you
you can't use it
wherever you want because it's not it's
not gonna like i think ocarina of time
if you threw it at a wall or a corner if
it got stuck in the corner you hear goes
it would find its way back right
but this if it hits any kind of object
yeah other than an enemy that thing is
gonna fall and it's gonna stay there and
you're gonna have to go pick it back up
it's trajectory stops in it yeah
or if you don't catch it
uh all right folks uh
i feel like we're talking in circles but
i don't know this game's really exciting
if you have any questions for us please
send them in the chat
um
yeah cause we we're happy to answer what
we can
yeah um
we really just want to be playing zelda
though so
uh yeah any other uh questions what was
there's one i forgot earlier that i
wanted to bring up but yeah here's more
footage oh so this is
this was so funny this was my early uh
experience with like
more of a personal experience through uh
bokoblin he was by himself and formed a
bond yeah well i was like this is so
great and i kept
exploding him and the ragdoll is really
awesome in this game uh
and he doesn't know i'm up here so he's
like getting more and more pissed off as
i'm just continually throwing him into a
wall uh it's great any sort of grappling
hook we haven't seen anything like that
that was a question not yet not yet
um
can you have your own house or have dogs
as companions
i don't know if you can have a dog as a
companion
that's all i'm gonna say
uh
they love you though yeah dogs dogs
[Music]
mount uh
taming a horse is completely different
like you have to um
uh you you there's a bond factor yes you
have to
you have to pet it when it's doing the
thing that you want it to do not like if
it's acting erratic be like hey it's
okay like you actually need to wait
until it it does the right thing and
then it will essentially learn right
yeah um it's it's tough you know there's
no opponent at this time or i don't know
if there is i think there's a rumor
saying that like you meet opponent but
you can't right yeah i haven't seen i
don't know i haven't seen her yet no
uh what can we say about the cape the
cape isn't really a cape it's sort of
part of like a hood that you wear
it's just for aesthetics uh but we can
talk about you know what let's talk
about that
it's so easy to look like a badass in
this game yeah like i you know i
remember
every other zelda game right you you
fight forever so you can get oh now i
got a red tunic look i'm red now
in this game like it just takes a
handful of minutes and then your shield
is different you've got like six
different weapons on you you know you've
got a spear across your back a bow and
arrow next to that and your shield and
you're running around just changing
between them all at once and even right
here i actually got i mixed and matched
like a
yeah like a sleepy rolling out of bed
dude i got metal legs uh i know about
now yeah uh you know the uh
uh hylian helium helium excuse me uh
cape and then uh yeah they um warm
doublet uh i believe for uh cold weather
so you can
man there's gonna be a point where
you're just gonna have
you're gonna have styles
uh
i don't know yeah there's there's a lot
of customization there um
i forgot what else i was going with
how do you feel about the uh the
variation in enemy types at the moment
yeah they're uh they're different so you
know everyone's just seeing these
bokoblins right um pretty much i run
into some other ones that are different
that are more aggressive that
you know have uh more of a long-range
aspect to them but then they will charge
you uh yeah and mess you up you're
you're learning it's you know it's
very much like having just played you
know a little bit of a horizon you run
into these machines right and you got to
change the way you play and that's the
same case here for every one of them the
the skeletons are my favorite they're
super easy to beat um but basically when
you attack them at first their head
falls off
and
it doesn't lose any health so what you
have to do is attack the head but if you
leave the head rolling around
that skeleton will try to put his head
back on now let's say you knock another
skeleton's body off a cliff and then you
knock the heads off of two skeletons a
skeleton will go for any head that's
close enough doesn't have to be its own
i had a really interesting experience
where a skeleton a skull fell off a
cliff
and it like chewed and rolled its way
back up the cliff to get to its body and
the bodies they're like hello
[Music]
uh people keep asking about the joy cons
uh did you guys keep asking no no
problems for us
just the way it is yeah
um let's see
lots of questions about apps uh we
currently don't really have a great idea
of what apps are available on the switch
os itself
um
at the moment there's more apps in
zelda's
tablet than there
was on this but here's a good one what
about saving the game
in terms of i just in general you can
save anywhere you can save anywhere at
any point yeah but it didn't look like
you could you could have hard saves as
and i could go back to an early early
save right you can't juggle manual saves
yeah
you'll have like six auto saves to
choose from something like that the auto
saves are great yes um
it's kind of surprising how seamless it
is too i mean there must be a ticker in
the bottom left but i don't notice it
but you know anytime you die it's like
oh perfect it's right where i would want
to be
yeah uh people asking do we worry about
scratching the screen and putting it
into the dock so i've got a screen
protector on mine so it's it hasn't even
crossed my mind but yours doesn't
have you had any concerns about that
like do you find yourself being pretty
careful when putting it in
oh screen protector isn't like a film
yeah there's a film on this oh mine does
not that's what i'm saying ah keep up
buddy damn i'm sorry i didn't even know
that yeah so yeah i mean do you notice
that there's any like danger do you feel
sheepish when you put that thing in
there no i feel a little sheepish um but
where i'm um
most concerned is uh because i don't
have a carrying case like
the dock isn't much of a concern for me
um there is there is padding underneath
or in the dock for the screen i don't oh
really yeah there's like it's like a
little it's like a little bit of a um
like a spongy film i don't know if we
can actually just take
well there are two yeah right here
oh i see yeah so there's padding that
separates it from the actual plastic oh
nice okay um
but no again i've said before oh you
totally missed it
um i said before it's uh
like there is this there's this
instinct
idea of sliding it into like a coat
pocket right but man you better make
sure there's no keys in there uh you you
want a case like it is there is a fear
of like scratching this thing for sure
yeah and it's kind of why i don't see
again we talked about like you know
playing it portable outside or something
like that
i would not recommend that to anyone
yeah like it is portable it's it's a
convenient size but it just i'm finding
myself
just happy to have that in the home
because the wii u sort of like teased
that feature like yeah you can play
games remotely on your couch without
your tv if you're like five feet away
mlg in the park guys yeah either by ten
yeah yeah it's just
i wouldn't do that but yeah definitely
carrying case i did not know about this
film so this came with it or you went in
like it came with the
the official nintendo case so if you buy
that you get a protective film with it
okay so uh that needs to be on there
yeah definitely definitely i would
recommend getting that yeah and again i
would say as well like if you're you
know you think about putting this thing
in your jacket i said this earlier like
don't leave these joy-cons on and even
if there is
this potential problem with the left
joy-con
uh
i would
is it a sensor thing do you know much
about what this this uh fear or rumor is
if it's even a rumor because i haven't
looked into it too much because i
haven't had to like worry about it on my
end yeah but it seems to be that it's
like a calibration desync okay happening
so it's pr
maybe it's something related to the
bluetooth radio like where it's
positioned in here or maybe it's just
software related like i assume it's got
to be something they can fix with
software um because it'd be weird to
have this many pieces of hardware
failing but not all of them
if it was actually a hardware issue and
there there is a calibration option in
the settings there's a count yes
check out the the video by game explain
um because we haven't had the issue we
can't really produce any content around
it because we can't speak to it but he
uh they did a very good video on it so
if you go to youtube and look that up
you can find it it's good resource if
you're curious
um yeah talk about rupees i didn't get
rupees until like a couple hours in the
game
third round i yeah you mean it's it's
like a zelda kill jesus chris it's like
a zelda game you like i you know throw
some pots
uh i didn't find any in pots
i've only found them
under rocks
pots under rocks no
movies
no yeah uh
under rocks i found a few they're around
uh and you're also um
you know there are
i
feel like i'm going too far you know
you know they're side quests
sure with rewards i've been just selling
materials and resources to get most of
my stuff
oh really yeah most of my money yeah
yeah
um
yeah you're definitely like flipping
shields that you find yeah there's
there's there are tons of ways like to
get any kind of cash like it's it's all
there
yeah i
yeah i don't i
at this point i feel like there's
someone about to
send in a squad
yeah nintendo's got pretty tight
restrictions on what we can and cannot
talk about um
is nintendo switch waterproof
no
let's try it out
um
yes he did just call me a silly goose
uh oh someone else asked did we go right
to the final boss from the beginning i
guess technically it's possible oh we
have this clip uh
we'll talk while jean-luc pulls it up um
john luke the uh guardian clip rights um
yeah perfect so this was the first enemy
they showed in that first e3 trailer
like three four years ago where link was
fighting off horse and like did that
flip and shot narrow into this thing
these are surrounding the final boss in
the final location
so and one hit kills yeah and they track
you and so presumably you'd have to be
able to dodge
any number of them like i haven't gotten
close enough to see if they're like i've
seen some that are mobile i've seen some
that are in the ground like i guess it'd
be possible but you gotta you gotta be
really good i don't know i don't think
i'm bad at this game but i don't think i
could do it i i don't like
maybe you know
by like a miracle you could get to the
gate of of you know uh calamity ganon
but yeah there those things are insane i
have i've been avoiding them at this
point uh and you probably will as well
within the first uh i mean half of hours
like they're just insanely overpowered
like you're on a horse like
the horse could freak out
and
and it's just one shot and then you're
off the horse and i like i ran like two
of those guys
sayonara no bueno yeah
[Music]
uh
rob what kind of conditioner do you use
is pantene i bet it's pantene [ __ ]
i was up really late playing and i like
stumbled into work i need a haircut
that's not important um i think it's
probably time to start uh wrapping up
here um we've pretty much said
everything we can about zelda so far
it's amazing
um i
i don't want to be here i just want to
be playing the game
but thank you guys for joining us a lot
we've got a lot more coverage on the way
and a lot on the site already uh mid to
late next week we're going to have the
hardware review and then we're going to
have the official zelda review 3 a.m
pacific time next thursday
be sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel for all that content you can get
it right away or check us out over on
gamespot thanks again for joining us and
uh we're looking forward to the switch
have a going see ya
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]